[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Here are 10 tips
to engage your readers,
encourage them to read
more of their content,
and help you monetize
your news app.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
1, listen to your
readers feedback
and analyze their behavior.
Read and reply to app reviews
in the Google Play Developer
Console, and use
Google Analytics
to measure and analyze
user behavior to help
you find where they disengage.
This will help you modify your
app to encourage engagement.
2, know your
readers with Sign In
so you can better engage them.
Google Sign In is a secure
authentication system
that reduces the burden
of login for your users,
by enabling them to sign in
with their Google account,
the same account they already
use with Gmail, Play, Google,
and other Google services,
even on iOS and desktop.
Once a reader has signed in, you
can personalize the experience.
3, help readers to rediscover
your app with notifications.
Help readers rediscover
your app using breaking news
and content update-rich
notifications.
Make sure you provide readers
with control over what
and when they're
notified so they
can keep up with the news
that matters to them.
4, build monetization
strategies that
meet your readers expectations.
You can choose from
using subscriptions
to offer premium
features or content,
selling a paid app on Google
Play, using a one-off in app
purchase to offer premium
features or content,
or gaining ad revenue,
such as from display
ads from your inventory with
DoubleClick for Publishers.
5, mix and match billing
models to capture
more reader's loyalty.
Use in-app purchases to offer
one-off content or premium
features, for example,
providing a special one-off news
report as an audio podcast
for a one-off payment
is a great way to
capture your readers.
Using ads will also help
to boost your revenue.
6, optimize your subscription
price proposition
for your readers.
If you decide on a
subscription model,
offer subscriptions that
appeal to readers' interests,
encouraging commitment through
scale pricing, and make sure
they're available on all
of the readers' devices.
Options include weekly, monthly,
quarterly, every six months,
and annual.
Differentiate entry
pricing significantly
from the normal subscription
to keep the entry barrier low,
for example, by
progressively discounting
longer running subscriptions.
7, utilize promotional
features of Google Play Billing
to increase your
subscriber conversion.
Use promo codes and
goodwill credits
to reward loyal subscribers
of your premium paid content.
Offer subscribers the ability
to upgrade and capture
lower spenders by introducing
them to lower-priced offers.
8, utilize free trials
to increase subscribers.
Using Google Play Billing, you
can offer readers a free trial
and customize the
time period so that it
works for your business, for
example, 5, 7, 30, or 60 days.
When readers sign up
to the free trial,
they enter their
payment details,
so if they don't cancel
the subscription,
they'll turn into regular
paying subscribers
once the free trial is complete.
9, understand your user's
behavior and subscription
patterns.
Use the Google Play
Developer Console
to track user acquisition.
This provides funnel
reporting, covering
store listing visits,
installs, purchases,
and repeat purchases.
It also includes user-to-buyer
conversion reporting.
These reports let you visualize
how your different audiences
compare, in other words,
track your progress in terms
of conversion rates.
They also provide a conversion
as a function of time.
You'll see when
customer retention
is starting to plateau.
They'll help you identify where
you have the biggest drop-offs
and where you can improve.
10, maximize revenue
from your ad inventory.
With DoubleClick
for Publishers, you
can deliver ads to all your
digital touch points, desktop,
mobile web, and your app.
Then use the marketplace,
offered by DoubleClick Ad
Exchange, to acquire inventory
from many leading advertisers.
Head over to Google
Play Developer
Console to start taking
advantage of these features.
If you want more tips on how
to improve your news apps
and build a better
mobile business,
check out the other
videos in this series
and download the News
Publisher's Playbook.